is very important
the enemies Islam notice that
terminology does affect people
it has impacts on people more than
weapons sometimes
so and this is the way of a shaytan if
you notice Iblis
when Allah
if this came to Adam he said to him
a tree of Eternity so iblees he knows
that if he says to Adam go into the
truth Allah made Haram for you he's not
going to listen to him so whatever is
did cherish the name of the tree by
calling the tree of Eternity subhanallah
and even he said and the Dominion that
is Everlasting
and this was happening now they say
we're here to empower women in another
word in another way we are here to
misguide woman
of course I'm not going to tell you
we're here to misguide your Muslim
movement they let you know we hire to
free you to empower you but what I
really mean to misguide you so be aware
of this seminologist freedom and uh what
they call it empowerment and so on look
what is behind it